[Music]
cara is with us cara is going to start
off this hour in rhode island hi cara
how are you
hey dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so just um kind of a quick question
when you have
a longer a probably longer than average
time horizon for baby step two that's
where we're on right now
um does it still make sense at that
point to completely pause retirement
savings we're both in our i'm 32 my
husband's 33.
um
i'm just wondering because we have about
140 000 worth of miscellaneous debt not
including our mortgage and
just doing the numbers and everything
it's probably going to be a few years
and we are you know kind of scrimping
and saving and stuff but i just
my employer does offer me a match on my
uh 401k and i can do a roth so i was
just wondering if
should i just complete
lose out on that time
you know what i mean yes
yes
you need to lose out on that time you
need to completely focus on that there
is a power that is unleashed when you
focus exclusively on something
that is not unleashed when you disperse
your emotions and your spirit across
several things
okay so complete obsession
the scream and howl at the moon
i'm getting out of that
that's what gets you out of debt
there's this i'm going to be smart and
i'm going to intellectually figure out
all these things does not get anybody
anywhere and that's why we have a
culture of broke people walking around
acting like they're smart
not you other people you're sweet you
called and asked a question but that's
why all these people are strutting
around with car payments acting like
they're somebody and they're not that's
just straight up stupid and they are
stupid when they're doing that i was
stupid when i did it and so you just
this exclusive focus supersedes the
power of the match and the compound
interest over the scope of your life
because it sets new grooves and habits
and principles into your brain where you
never change what's your household
income
uh we're just we're just under a hundred
thousand okay and how much of the
hundred and forty thousand is car
uh about
eighteen thousand
on one car
no on cue cars okay all right yeah we
had a stupid fleece and you've been
working on this program for a month and
a half maybe what how long
um
no it
we we messed up last year um so we
we stopped and we started again
so yes at this point i have like we have
refocused and it's we're probably on
three months now okay that's about right
that's what i get i figured you were
early in the game yeah no we are we like
seriously
but this time but this time of year
this time you're serious
yes yes
and then you look up and you go i'm
serious and that's a tall freaking
mountain that i'm seriously got to climb
ouch scary intimidated overwhelmed right
ken yeah i so let's let's help you
really focus here for a second so how
much you contributing to the 401k let's
just do simple math what's coming out of
your check for that
um well
this is why i wanted to call and ask
because i had i had dialed it down to 3
so uh like a hundred bucks 120 bucks
that's fine for this example
so what's your smallest debt you're
familiar with what we teach in baby step
two you take the smallest debt first so
what's your smallest debt round numbers
if you don't know it exactly yeah um no
no no worries um we're fit i'm finishing
up a just a medical bill that was that's
got about 600 bucks left on it all right
so
you're not you know 100 bucks take out
taxes but if you just put a hundred
bucks or 50 bucks a month and you just
attack that medical loan boom you're
done with that what's the next highest
one
it's a uh a lawyer bill for my husband's
uh student loan that's 1400 bucks right
so those are manageable and as dave's
talking about you guys getting at this
then all of a sudden here's what you're
gonna experience we know this we've
heard this from tens of thousands of
people you're gonna experience momentum
after a couple of those because you go
wait a second we've sacrificed maybe
he's working an extra job we're selling
everything and all of a sudden you get
momentum and that 140 000 isn't so scary
anymore because you see yourself
attacking this thing and we're getting
there we're getting there we're getting
there so being really really disciplined
right now and clear that the process
works you just have to taste a couple of
victories so
here's
let me
if i were to do a weighted
average approach to your situation okay
um
one percent of you succeeding
financially
in the scope of the next 10 years is
whether or not
mathematically is whether or not you do
this match or not
it's a hundred bucks
you can sneeze and lose that
it doesn't matter
let me show you how much it doesn't
matter
okay how many times do you have to do
100 bucks to pay off an 18 000 car a lot
and yet i didn't jump on and sell your
cars
why didn't i do that because as a ratio
of the overall problem they don't fix
the problem this hundred bucks doesn't
fix the problem selling the cars doesn't
fix the problem but what really does fix
the problem 85 to 90 percent of the the
mayonnaise on the bologna sandwich the
thing that makes it work here 85 to 90
percent of the reason you're going to
succeed is your complete focus and
sellout and sticking to this and tearing
into it and working extra and selling so
much stuff the kids think they're next
and not seeing the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and you're doing the budget and you and
your husband are working and all you're
thinking about for the next 24 to 36
months is i'm getting out of debt and
you know anybody that says anything to
you you just yell at him get away from
me you know just do i'm just doing this
i'm freaking doing this and that's the
people that get out of debt it's not an
intellectual exercise
it's a visceral
roar at the moon coming from down inside
your soul that i freaking had it and i'm
not living like this anymore that's 85
to 95 of this that is represented by
your willingness to quit playing
ftse with the mathematics of a hundred
dollars
yes the emotional representation inside
your
soul
uh that that you gave up this holy match
from your employer that everyone
worships oh my god that's the answer
it's wonderful to get a match by the way
but everybody acts like it's a big thing
the big thing is you
you're the deal you're the secret sauce
personal finance is 80 behavior it's 20
head knowledge when you get your
emotions your relationships the
psychology of who you are all dialed in
and you go that's it
i've had it i'm sick and tired of being
sick and tight it's when you change your
life baby
it's not when you drop the match or
start the match it's not when you
suddenly understand compound injuries
it's not even when you sell your
eighteen thousand dollars worth of cars
out of a hundred forty thousand dollars
for the debt when you make 100 000 a
year
you'll find a way
when you've had it
and that's the deal